[Music]
my ultimate Christmas day is relaxed
affair with great food when you're well
prepared there's no need to rush
so once the turkeys underway Christmas
morning in the Ramsey household always
starts with a late breakfast of
deliciously creamy scrambled eggs and
smoked salmon this recipe is a Ramsey
family's Edition on Christmas Day smoked
salmon scrambled egg and cross on its
rich sumptuous and incredibly easy to do
first the croissants slice them into
rounds and season them lightly with salt
as that's the secret behind a really
good breakfast is in the timing on the
crystals on first smoked salmon on top
and then the scrambled egg put the
questons in a dry pan and toast
you don't need oil because the quasars
have a lot of butter in them this is a
great way to transform day-old
croissants giving them a delicious new
life just start to see them toasting
almost listening in the pan and that's
the butter inside as smell is amazing it
almost smells like a sort of camera lies
waffle absolutely delicious toast them
all around both sides and then out next
just getting a smoked salmon sort of
twist it and let it fall over the
croissant let it sit naturally on top of
the toasted croissant
[Music]
or twist over right
scrambled eggs eggs into the pan never
whip up the a34 hand you break down the
egg too much what I wanted a really nice
rich creamy scrambled egg eggs in no
seasoning at this stage a nice generous
knob of butter now from there
onto the heat and all you do now is stir
stir and stir and stir
[Music]
now the butter is melting and has given
a really nice creamy texture to the eggs
it looks rich delicious sumptuous
luxurious if you very careful making
scrambled egg all of a sudden it looks
funny and within 30 seconds it's cooked
working it all the time right after
stirring a place this scraper in there
take the pan off the heat and just work
around the pan cleaning up all that
scrambled egg that's sticking to the
bottom and now look we're getting that
really nice sort of creamy beautiful
texture little touch of butter in there
now I'm gonna start with the seasoning
30 seconds on the end
salt pepper back on to the stove and a
tablespoon of cream the cream actually
stops the scrambled egg from overcooking
cream in and then fold that in there now
keep that off the heat but look at it
look at that color
beautiful
and then finally some fresh chives
[Music]
this Ramsey classic smoked salmon
toasted croissant and a delicious
scrambled egg
the best start the Christmas Day anyone
could wish for
you